dem habe ich geschrieben hey du bist
doch alex mitte wurde habe die nummer
mit unserer klasse gruppe kannst du bist
alles schon wieder grüßen
[Musik]
es klappt netz bekommen bei myvideo ja
leute ich freue mich auf dieses video so
lange wie vor dem kauf auf jeden fall
freue ich mich auch dieses video so sehr
wie schon lange nicht mehr auf irgendein
anderes video bereich mega botter und
zwar ist mir gestern die flüsse ist auf
jeden fall ist mir gestern wirklich die
ultimative idee gekommen für ein neues
video
ihr wisst bescheid ich habe vor einem
halben jahr mal den ein oder anderen
whatsapp prank durchgeführt und ich hab
mich jüngere dass alex da muss irgendwas
revolutioniert werden da muss was neues
kommen und ich habe da eine idee
entwickelt also das ding ist das
funktioniert nur weil ich würde mal
sagen etwas größeren youtuber weil sonst
ist es eigentlich egal ob wohl um
ehrlich zu sein das wird natürlich auch
bei anderen menschen gehen aber bei
youtube ist natürlich etwas anderes und
er teilt euch wenig fett die idee jetzt
gratis also ich hab hier einmal mein
handy und hier habe ich noch ein anderes
handy jederzeit ich hatte einfach zwei
iphones ein iphone 6 glaube ich und ein
iphone 6 plus und darum diesen flug
schon so lang ein flugzeug gesehen recht
schnell so und für dieses handy also das
ist jetzt mein handy was ich heute
brauchte
nutzen sie den korb eingehen so dass
jetzt das handy was heute brauche und
war habe ich von meinem handy hier
schnell rüber geschickt ein paar nummern
und zwar einmal die nummer von marx
bradley wie ein junger von herab da noch
die nummer von heike von den noch ist
und als letztes noch die nummer von
meinem mitbewohner weil mein mitbewohner
hat was das angeht immer richtig pfarrer
der wurde nämlich letztens ein gerufen
von irgendeinem mädchen oder so und
sollte mich als schöne grüße bestellen
und wir wissen nicht woher das mädchen
die nummer hat oder wäre zwar keine
ahnung deswegen habe ich mir den auch
judo der plan sieht folgendermaßen aus
ich werde einfach von diesem handy den
schreiben deswegen müssen jetzt erst mal
das web profil ein bisschen
umstrukturieren das hier ist dass der
name geändert werden
nenne ich es einfach mal sarah und ich
muss natürlich auch das profilbild
ändern wird sagen dafür team jetzt
einfach mal ein schönes snapshot kunde
filter bild aus dem internet leute ich
hab mir kraft gefunden und zwar dass
hier man es sehen
das passt auf jeden fall richtig gut so
dass wir jetzt eingestellt und dann war
ich einfach folgendes ich schreibe hey
ich kann alex der hat mir deine nummer
wie ich bin großer fan von dir blabla
können wir ein bisschen schreiben oder
sonstwas und wir fangen wir an wie die
personen reagieren
ich bin ja gespannt ich würde sagen als
erstes schreiben bei dem markt und dem
schreiben war hätte dem markt ist
folgendes geschrieben vermag ich bin
sarah ich habe die nummer von alexa lag
wie weil ich schade ich echt so gerne
und schon so lange und er merkt auch in
anleihen und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ob der markt hier zurück schreibt oder
ob tierpark mir hier schreibt mike annen
vortag
sollte der markt hat der gratis foto
geschickt hat einfach mitglieder von
chat ich tue jetzt einfach mal so als
wüsste ich gar nichts davon wohin habe
ich nichts
erstmals schreibt minecraft hast du in
video mich mal angerufen oder
geschrieben so dass man meine nummer
sieht also von mir die definitiv nicht
wie redet man ganze und beschreibende
blieben merkmal wird im markt wurde
folgendes noch von der firma geschrieben
hatten wir beantworten ich gebe dir auch
kein weiter auch darin nicht antwortet
weil in meiner studie kennt nicht viele
format
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
wahrscheinlich kriegt mal greift ein
bisschen ein so in der zwischenzeit
jemand schon mal schnell rüber zu
herausnehmen stein war oh mein gott bist
du wirklich heraus und wir gehen mal
sofort über zu meinem mitbewohner im
juni und im juli schreiber hey du willst
du bist doch alex mit bruder habe ihn
immer und unserer klasse bekannt dass
alexander grüßen
ich hoffe der fans jetzt richtig ein
weiterer schock weil er denkt jetzt
wahrscheinlich so die nummer es halt in
der klasse gruppe vereinigt so gut was
hat eine liebe mag geschrieben
du weißt man kann mich nicht drängen
aber man muss man sagen du die idee oder
so mag antwortet grad in der
zwischenzeit gehen wir mal schnell zu
heiko und heiko streibich
oh mein gott schreibt irgendwie immer oh
mein gott hab ich geschrieben oh mein
gott heiko hat nummer von alexei er
meint ist die echte ich liebe euch so
markert geantwortet wie schon
geschrieben nicht antworten
immerhin erwartet um mich rum konnten
heute was soll ich sagen wir warten
jetzt mal ab die anderen also bisher
nichts antwortet könnte etwas dauern
deswegen manchmal kurzen pause 61 den
speck spinnrad ein bisschen deprimiert
aus folgendem grund regel folgt eine
antwort ich sitze ich jetzt bei einer
finde ich die ganze zeit beide handys ja
das ist hart an sich ziemlich deprimiert
weil ich wollte das video noch gleich
schnell schneider dann umsetzen uns für
euch online stellen
der grund warum es erst später kommt wo
sich alles zu kulanz antworten
[Musik]
hahahaha so wurde zum einen spricht von
heiko stimmt nicht ich erwarte jetzt
einfach mal fallen ist so ja ich glaub
ich hab dir die vor zwei tagen oder so
gegeben aber die hat mich halt so lange
fragten die feier echt mega du dich
schon auch länger also deswegen
vielleicht kein feind vielleicht planung
so ein bisschen mehr schreiben einfach
voll 3d heraus und mein mitbewohner was
ist los mit euch wie ihr könnt ihr nicht
antworten wirklich wenn man so mit den
abhängen so durchgehend am handy egal wo
in meinem handy aus
warum wurde die kemp auf er hatte ich
zudem keine auf so leute die spaß an
ich bin mal gespannt was jetzt kommen
ohne witz ob ich mir das glaubt oder
nicht ich habe um 11.30 angefangen jetzt
ist es 12 und 37 und das ist eigentlich
nicht viel bei rumgekommen erster jäger
warum bist du denn jetzt offline was ich
mir aber auch gut vorstellen könnte
was treibt dich so er weiß dass ich
niemals eine nummer weitergeben würde am
meisten hoffnungen setzt sich daheim ein
messer wurde dass der jetzt überhaupt
nicht schlecht aber der gegend zu
verantworten
[Musik]
also wenn du dir weh ich denke ich hatte
eine nummer weitergeben
wer an sich soll das war ja mein ziel
dass das jemand denkt und ich hab's
geschafft wahrscheinlich ist erst gerade
auf mich 2000 jahre später leute ob ihr
es glaubt oder nicht wir haben gerade 14
uhr 120 ich wollte das video und 14
online stellen ich krieg einfach von
juri und herab keine antwort warum auch
immer
okay leute kurzer nachtrag ich weiß wir
sehen können juli also monate geschenkt
so helfer klare durchsagen
das ist das ding in screenshots ohne
spaß hast du irgendwo deine nummer oder
so angegeben
weiters kann als wenn also haben hat die
noch eine andere geschrieben oder nur
die meinte die irgendwie eine klasse hat
also da was aber heute hat jetzt eine
geschrieben zwei haben die heute
geschrieben
die eine die dir geschrieben hat die
gesagt hat großmann luisa das war echt
erweisen
so habe ich auch gerade
aber die runter angeschrieben
sonst hatte ich dann gesagt nein ich hab
auch ich habe auch versucht markant zu
kriegen aber der hat getagt und heike
halt und terrasse aber der bisher nicht
beantwortet tut mir auch leid aber das
video schon acht minuten oder zu lang
deswegen aus wie lange lässt ist erstmal
hierbei ich weiß ich hab doch nicht so
viel erreicht ja aber ich habe mir
vorgenommen das wird auf jeden fall noch
besser deswegen mandy bork hat auch die
zweite folge dann lasst auf jeden fall
nach oben da und dann versuche ich auch
mal irgendwie so ein paar freunde von
mir dran zu kriegen wenn jetzt zu ziehen
und schauen ja an sich finde ich die
idee nämlich ziemlich gut einfach leute
durch
ich habe deine nummer academy kommentar
schreiben was ihr davon haltet und wenig
so von youtube erpressen doll von einen
oder anderen habe ich eventuell die
nummer wir sehen uns haut rein folgt auf
emsdetten ganz wichtig sondern konnten
als die teams jetzt nur so vor durch das
anfahren